j'ai un petit cadeau pour isabelle
morini bosc il savait lointain mais ce
qu'on va faire un petit jeu on va jouer
à la nuda mix c'est à dire que moi aussi
j'ai repris des chansons de charles
aznavour c'est à dire j'ai pris et
chansons de charles aznavour et gémit
d'autres paroles dessus à vous de
trouver les deux interprètes vous jouez
avec nous bien sûr chez vous sur twitter
et vous jouez avec nous aussi
autour de la table voici la première
chance c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu parles avec une à une à une à une à
10 heures mes proches m'appellent walden
ouais je dirais oui je m'appelle weather
à l'épée du pontet caleçon st
irrité car son seul
mais quand tu es tu as
la tchéquie alors isabelle c'est qui
attention isabelle essayer de trouver la
deuxième c'est parti
magath et rs 4 green ardo bien sûr
qu'ils m'ont gratter le soleil dans ma
bulle sur le prado
c'est le shifter vos crocs autre sens et
ma chérie tu es à contresens mais dis
moi tu étais où quand je m'étais 7 euros
d'essence jeu s'est passé là-bas gatti
qui vient de moi après je vais déjà
quitté un petit tabac ouais je deviens
qui tu es
non ce n'est pas la capitale c'est
marseille 3 au 10 sport se passe la
douane et je passais rapin attention
alors
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
allez je prends je prends ces
technologies
bref tous les héros du très organisé ils
font un carton en bande organisée cet
été du moment et jule team-aaa qui j'ai
discuté en dm sur turin ce tas je fais
un gros bisou merci pour son petit mot
qui m'a fait très plaisir attention
dernier titre c'est pour vous
normalement pouvait pas passer à côté de
ce que j'entends déjà les santonniers
sont isolées et sans tout cela
ghadames au studio et avec des présents
les bras c'était quoi
maintenant j'ai pas compris assez ça
elle va va mourir touché au bal masqué
bande du roi
c'est la compagnie créole qui sont cons
ces jeunes et beaux visages
[Applaudissements]